well thanks everybody for joining me and
it's my first time at Stanford so very
exciting and it's great to be part of
the seminar with such a great group of
speakers so I'm going to talk today
about what I call photo mystery-solving
photo mysteries which is to me a very
interesting challenge talk a little bit
about more about it soon but this idea
that we're going to make sense of photos
given little or no context what's being
pictured when was this photo taken where
was it created all these kinds of
questions and my approach to try to
solve these mysteries is going to be
what I call expert LED crowdsourcing and
I'll talk more about that as well but
basically the idea that experts and
novice crowds can collaborate and have
complementary strengths that can lead to
some really nice outcomes for these
investigations so I'll start with an
example that I hope I imagine many of
you are familiar with and this was a
terrible tragedy a few years ago the
Boston Marathon bombing and as many of
us know there was a an attack some bombs
went off some people were killed and
there was a manhunt to try to figure out
who was responsible for this and it took
a while to figure out who that was who
the perpetrators were and so the police
and law enforcement released photographs
of the event and the moments before to
try to enlist the public health to
figure out what might have happened is
there someone suspicious or is there
some evidence that there might be
something weird going on here and so a
lot of people and a lot of online
communities like Reddit and 4chan and
some others took up this opportunity to
say oh well we could we could figure
this out we can solve this mystery we
can catch these these criminals these
terrorists and until they tried and they
created a subreddit dedicated to solving
this mystery and maybe you encounter
data maybe you heard about it but lots
of different members of this community
tried to piece together this mystery
looking at different photographic
evidence
circling things that look suspicious
trying to draw connections across them
trying to propose different narratives
of the different sequences of events
that might have led to the attacks and
unfortunately this community read it as
well as the other ones were not
successful in identifying the correct
suspects however they did name some
other suspects who turned out to be
completely innocent so it was a it was a
real disaster and kind of a tragedy upon
a tragedy for those innocent people and
not surprisingly the the rest of the
world was pretty upset about this and
the news media in particular who would
traditionally be doing some of these
investigations and covering these
incidents was was really upset and just
went to town on the reddit community and
other communities that were trying to do
this calling it a witch hunt
you know vigilantes and the community of
reddit responded as well and and said uh
you know we're really sorry we're going
to shut down this forum we're going to
delete every bit of evidence related to
this discussion and then all kinds of op
eds came out later with you know these
witch hunts are awful these amateurs
shouldn't be bothering crowd-sourced
crime-fighting is a terrible idea and
this basically shouldn't ever be
attempted again we tried it and we
failed so I appreciate that response and
I recognize this as a prominent example
of a real failure but I personally am
NOT ready to just throw in the towel and
say crowdsourcing can contribute to
these kinds of investigations it has
nothing useful to offer instead I think
there might be a nice opportunity here
to link up these crowds who are
passionate about these mysteries who
want to solve who may have valuable
skills or information with experts who
can help guide these investigations make
sure that they don't go down a an
unethical path or that they stay on
track and that's kind of where this idea
of expert LED crowdsourcing comes from
and so as I mentioned the beginning of
the talk it's kind of a simple idea I
think that experts and crowds can have
complementary strengths experts have
this domain knowledge they know a whole
heck of a lot about a specific topic but
they also have limitations you know
they're individuals they only have so
much time and energy they can commit
there's only so many leaves they can
follow up on and in contrast crowds
rarely have that domain knowledge at
least the novice crowds that I typically
work with however they have a lot of
energy there are typically lots of them
so they can potentially work in parallel
they can collaborate they may have local
knowledge or diverse knowledge that the
expert might not have and so there's
some exciting potential here I think to
imagine how these two different groups
could work together on something like a
photo investigation so the work that I'm
going to talk about today is is trying
to imagine how that could look in the
context of investigations like the one
that I mentioned earlier and it kind of
draws on a lot of previous work in
crowdsourcing primarily a lot of it was
performed here Stanford and some of
those folks may even be in the room but
there's been a lot of really important
previous work that I'm building on here
so there's been studies of how leaders
can lead a crowd and maybe a novice or
maybe an expert can have some kind of
direction or delegation performed with
that crowd crowds that are composed of
experts like the flash teams work
explore here we have lots of different
people with different expertise is how
we can combine them to get some kind of
great result
crowd sense making sense making the idea
that we're trying to understand a
situation and we don't really even know
where to start we have to develop our
own schema of what's even happening
before we can start to piece it together
crowd visual analysis everything from
projects like Jeff Biggums vizwiz
project where we're helping blind people
recognize objects in their environment
using
crowd sourcing all the way up to some of
the crowdsource visual design critique
work that I've done and using crowds to
analyze things like Google Street view
images looking for evidence of
accessibility issues and finally if
these crowds are going to be interacting
with experts it probably needs to happen
in some reasonable time frame so there's
a lot of really nice work here from the
adrenaline project early on through
Walter Lucky's work with chorus and
Legion some real-time crowd sourcing -
most recently work here exploring how we
could very quickly categorize images
using using crowds so I'm trying to
build on the shoulders of giants here
excluding myself and and hopefully the
result will be something really even
more exciting than what we currently
have
so this domain of crowd investigations
in the context of something like the
Boston Marathon bombing can be narrowed
down a little more specifically to a
task called
image geolocation so here I'm talking
about given a photograph where exactly
on a map was this photo taken
I'd like to pinpoint that as
specifically as possible and this is one
of several or really endless questions
you could ask about a photo you could
say you know who is in the image when
was it taken for now I'm focusing on
where where was that image taken and
more specifically I'm talking about a
wide variety of images that might be
geo-located images that might come from
eyewitnesses to a crime or government
posting images of important events that
are taking place or even terrorist or
criminal organizations posting
propaganda a lot of this is coming in
through social media photos and videos
and I'm going to talk about this more of
it experts in this field they're
typically performing these dual
education tasks manually
they are often using open source tools a
wide variety I'll talk about that as
well and it's often a manual process
synthesizing this information
making sense of it whittling down the
possibilities so here's some examples of
the kinds of geolocation tasks we might
be interested in and you know you can
get an idea of the variety and there's a
lot of really interesting examples of
this work being performed online some by
experts some by online communities of
citizen investigators one of them is
known as Belling cat you might be
familiar with that a lot of really
interesting examples on that site and
what you can see in this example here is
a photo this is actually from a video of
some Tunisian jihadists and it was
posted online and folks are trying to
figure out where it was taken and they
were able to use including the images
some of distinctive architecture to then
identify a probable region this turned
out to be Raqqa and used this aerial
satellite imagery to narrow down the
exact location where that distinctive
architecture was present and ultimately
identify where they were and another
example these are some some pro-russian
trainees that we're posting photographs
of their training camp on social media
and trying to keep the location a secret
but the online communities were able
this particular one is Belling cat again
we're able to identify this location
from some of the distinctive geographic
features and ultimately figure out this
camps location which was just on on the
edge of the ukraine-russia border I
believe and this is valuable information
that it can then be used to corroborate
or dispute what claims are being made
either by my government or by the source
of these images so give you a little
preview for what else I'm going to talk
about basically what I'm going to start
with is I'm going to try to dig deep
into understanding how these experts
perform these to your location tasks and
I gave you a couple of examples
but overall we don't really know how
they do it we we don't know what their
process looks like we don't know what
their challenges are we don't know how
someone might be able to help them how
crowd might be able to help them so
following that I'm going to show a
system that we built called ground truth
that is informed by these studies with
experts and ideally will help them
perform their geolocation work using
crowdsourcing then I'm going to talk
about a couple of experiments that we
ran with crowd sourcing platforms to
explore how a novice crowd might be able
to do something as difficult as an image
geolocation and then finally not really
for studies it's really three studies
and a little teaser of a fourth study
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples of how experts are using ground
truth software for geolocation work so
let's jump in so starting out with this
first study I'm really trying to
understand what does geolocation look
like from an experts point of view I
mean as I mentioned before this is a
manual process for the most part they're
using a lot of different kinds of tools
they're synthesizing a lot of different
kinds of information how what exactly is
going on there so we conducted
interviews with a bunch of expert
geolocators in different domains each
one about an hour long we're asking
about their motivations why do they do
this what does that process look like
what challenges do they face who do they
collaborate with other experts or with
the crowd or with the public and what
kinds of tools and technologies do they
use and then we did a bottom-up analysis
of those transcripts so to give you a
sense of who these people were and maybe
a sense of what geolocation looks like
more broadly you can kind of see a
little bit who these people are and the
organizations that they represent so we
have private investigator we have a
researcher from the digital digital
forensic research lab we've got a couple
of journalists who work for a company
that does
social media verification for a lot of
major news media clients we have people
who work at large news agencies and a
handful of folks who wanted to remain
anonymous some again working for a large
news media agencies and others doing
work in security and intelligence and
other fields like that so it's kind of
interesting you can already get a sense
for this process of geolocation is
pretty broad a lot of different domains
a lot of different fields are trying to
do this for different reasons you know
someone at Amnesty International might
have a different goal than a private
investigator
but the geolocation work as I'll show
tends to look similar in a lot of ways
so I won't have time to get into all the
details of the interview study I'll just
touch on some of the key points that
helped inform our software development
but these are the general categories
that all that I'll run through so just
real quick talking about motivation I
think this is kind of interesting
because it helps underscore that
although this is a manual process that
can be tedious at times it is also very
rewarding to these experts and we're not
necessarily looking they're not
necessarily looking for someone to
replace their to replace them to do the
work for them
they are interested in help as we'll see
but some of them are really excited
about this work and they feel like
they're a detective there's an
adrenaline rush they think there's a
moral argument to debunking these facts
these claims that might be made
especially when when we're talking about
people being killed civilians being
killed and someone who has been a
journalist in a few different agencies
there's something appealing about being
so close to the raw fact that they are
almost being there as this one person
described
so talking about the process this is
actually a fairly long process the ones
in bold are the ones I'll go into a
little more detail on but very briefly
this is this is roughly the sequence of
steps that a person would go through to
perform geolocation first they're going
to find an image or video that they're
going to geo locate and that may be
provided to them or they may go looking
for it there's a number of ways then
they're going to try to gather context
about that image who uploaded it where
was it found was it on twitter was it on
Facebook
is there any metadata associated with it
are there any comments that have been
posted on it what kind of clues are
immediately visible in that image are
there
street signs are there geographic
features that we can use to draw some
conclusions if there aren't enough clues
to immediately identify the location
then the expert will typically draw a
diagram and an aerial diagram that will
try to convert that ground-level photo
into an overhead view and the reason
they're doing that is because there's n
going to take that overhead view that
diagram and try to compare that with
satellite imagery in Google Maps or in
Tara server or one of these other
satellite image sources and try to
compare visually the two different the
drawing with the location in real world
then they'll do the search itself going
through systematically trying to figure
out okay this isn't it this isn't it
this might be it looking in the entire
search space however broad that might be
at some point they might find what
they're looking for or they might not
and then at that point they have to know
when to quit okay this isn't going to
work I'm not going to find it or too
much time has passed it's no longer
important and then finally they'll
report that result you know depending on
who it is they might be writing up a
report for a client or they might be
writing a news story for the public or
some other kind of of dissemination so
digging a little deeper into some of
these steps gathering context this is
kind of differentiating between
identification tasks and verification
tasks
if this image or video is just totally
on its own then we don't really have a
whole lot of context but there might be
some claim associated with it the
government is saying this photo was
taken here or was taken on this date and
we're going to gather as much of that
information as possible if there's
metadata we're going to maybe use
software to grab any geo tags or any
exif data what kind of camera was used
but most social media platforms will
scrub this data so it's not available
the process is looking for clues this is
kind of amazing all the different kinds
of clues that the experts talked about
using really the list is endless
they were looking at science they're
looking at logos more surprising things
the shadows can be used to determine the
time of day different weather patterns
vegetation you name it they look for it
and then there's the image itself not
what the content of the image is but how
grainy is it if it's grainy it may have
been republished and we may question
that source is there been any obvious
manipulation or for advanced tools like
tungsten can be used to detect any
manipulation and ultimately they're
looking for these clues because they're
going to try to synthesize them and
narrow down the possibilities for
example if they have narrowed it down to
a city and they see a gas pump then
maybe they can go and research where all
the gas pumps in the city and then they
can systematically go through each one
so they're synthesizing this information
together to reach a conclusion some
other techniques that they use again the
that they're pretty much endless but a
couple that impressed me one group was
looking at recent satellite imagery and
noticing these craters the craters were
actually from mortars that were fired
and the shells hit the ground in a
particular pattern and it turns out you
can analyze that crater to determine the
location of the border that fired it
depending on the width of the radius and
all those kinds of things so this is
this is the kind of work that can be
done and this other example claim was
made about a certain kind
of missile truck that was in the area
and dependent the turning radius of that
particular vehicle and was able to look
at the tire tracks in the satellite
imagery and determine well that that
particular truck couldn't have made
those turns therefore it has to be
something else so incredible creativity
incredible variety and as I mentioned
sometimes those clues aren't enough and
so these experts have to draw a diagram
so what they might start out with is a
video or in this case a video this was a
sad incident where a reporter was killed
in Cairo and from this video they might
have to patch together a different scene
they'll produce a aerial overhead
diagram that reflects the structures the
key distinctive elements and structures
in that video and then they'll comb
through satellite imagery of that
location and try to find a match and it
can take a long time or it may never
work out but as you can see in this case
they were able to figure out where
exactly that attack took place and once
you have developed this diagram you have
to compare to get something so you need
to go and find some reference imagery
and different services are better and
for different locations for example
Google Street View is great for the US
and select other countries but a lot of
countries don't have Street View and in
some cases being has better satellite
image quality then Google Maps does or
Google Earth the experts had very
specific claims about which of these
services were better in different
situations they also use a lot of non
satellite imagery to kind of get a feel
for the area they look on Flickr they
look on penury Mia which unfortunately
no longer exists and try to see other
kind of on-the-ground evidence so as I
mentioned there are other steps involved
but I wanted to give you a feel for the
the most critical steps in the process
in terms of this work we also asked
those experts about crowdsourcing and
whether or not they ever used the public
you know asking for tips or seeking
specific kinds of information and they
had pretty strong opinions about what
crowds shouldn't shouldn't do in terms
of helping them with their geolocation
work
so things the crowd could do or had done
for them
simple definable tasks may be providing
more reference imagery that they might
have access to noticing things that the
expert might miss kind of another pair
of eyes maybe they might have some
specialized local knowledge they live
there they've been in the area before
they could tell you things that that
person wouldn't know who hasn't been
there and then the other thing the
crowds they felt shouldn't do that
really experts are better suited for any
kind of analysis work while synthesizing
making interpretations of the evidence
anything that required interaction so
it's one thing to gather information
that's available online is another to go
out and and ask a source where did you
get this photo or go on to the ground on
the field and start talking to people
any kind of confirmation the expert is
really the person make the final call
about whether this is accurate or not
and then a certain topics that were very
sensitive that could really impact
people's lives or the content itself
could be very upsetting maybe best left
to the experts so then finally we asked
them about some challenges and that they
were facing and ways that perhaps we
might be able to help and they had a
number of these as well one of them is
certainly the fact that speed is
critical to this work oftentimes they
need this information within half an
hour or less and it's interesting to get
this insight from one of the experts you
know he says I'm a journalist first I'm
not a forensic scientist so I'm
interested in getting the story right
but I'm particularly interested in
getting it right for my agency and not
having someone else get there first
there's also an issue with using all
these different tools a lot of like
applying
like tools that are scattered all over
the web this one participant had a
colorful way of talking about it go find
something like Jeffrey's exit viewer and
it looks at da G's at box of frogs these
tools aren't consistent they may not be
reliable they may disappear that makes
their work a lot more difficult very
rural or urban areas not enough clues or
just an abundance of clues overwhelming
sites like Twitter that will remove
metadata and the subsequent laundering
of content where an image is reposted
many times and you lose the trail of
where it originated and trolling the
experts mentioned they see an increase
in deliberate trolling where people are
purposefully trying to mislead them with
the content they put up so some some
high-level takeaways we saw we saw these
processes and and patterns tended to be
consistent across these different
domains which is promising for anyone
that might want to build any
technologies to support these challenges
because they might have broader
applicability applicability experts are
already using crowds and crowdsourcing
often in low-tech ways but they're open
to this idea for the most part and
they've had some success a lot of the
tasks that are being performed by these
experts we could imagine some of those
things being offloaded to novice crowds
certainly not everything but they had a
variety of ideas for what could be
possible and the experts almost
unanimously said they're overburdened
they have too much work to do there's
too many images coming in they don't
have time for all this so if they could
get useful help they would really
embrace that they would appreciate that
so that's kind of where we decided we
would try to jump in and create some
kind of tool that would support this
geolocation work and our idea was we
would start with this satellite image
analysis problem where we have a bunch
of imagery that needs to be looked
through and we have an expert who is
looking for a specific thing
and you can imagine a bunch of different
ways that might work so maybe a an
obvious approach or a naive approach
might be okay well we have a photo and
we want to geolocate it so maybe we have
a bunch of satellite imagery and we'll
ask the crowds to look at that photo and
look for a section of the satellite
imagery and great maybe they'll find it
or maybe not but we have a lot of
reasons to think that probably wouldn't
work experts talked about how the mental
process of translating this image into
this photo into an aerial diagram is
difficult it takes practice it's a
cognitive skill that not everyone has
and so what we imagine is that perhaps
there's an opportunity to leverage an
existing practice of those experts to
kind of bridge the gap and he'll allow
these crowds to help the experts and
that bridge could be one of these
diagrams experts are already creating
them as part of their own process what
if we could share that diagram with
crowds would that actually help them do
this task easier or would it be an
impediment compared to something like
the original original photo and that's
what we aim to find out so we developed
this system that I mentioned called
ground truth it's a web-based system the
idea is that the expert produces one of
these diagrams like they typically would
for themselves but then they can specify
an area of the map that they want a
crowd to help them search and so the
crowd will be looking through this
satellite imagery at the same time that
the expert is doing their own
investigation but the crowds results can
help the expert prioritize picking the
areas of the most promising that have
the most potential that look most like
the original image so what I'm going to
do is I'm actually going to show a quick
video of the system first that we ended
up with and then I'm going to get into
some of the details of the studies
we conducted to to get it where it is
now and explain some of the choices the
design choices that we made
okay so this is the expert view of
ground truth on the left you have the
source image this is the mystery image
we're trying to figure out and then here
we have the diagram that the expert is
drawn the aerial diagram and on the
right here is the search area so what
they're doing right now is they're
choosing a sub-region size I think every
time I click it picks that noise sorry
I'll point so they're picking a size
that they want to be a basically a
rectangle that a crowd worker would look
through and compare against the diagram
that you see here so that's going to be
based on basically the same size as the
diagram that's been generated the expert
can turn these the satellite imagery on
and off they can turn the map and the
labels on and off but ultimately they
pick some location they think is
promising and they draw a rectangle like
this so the rectangle will then be
converted into a grid and that grid is
now being sent out to a bunch of crowd
workers so here's a crowd worker
interface the workers been assigned this
16 grid 16 grid square here rectangle
and they're going to go through each one
and if they see something that looks
like the expert diagram they're going to
mark that as a yes or maybe if they
don't see a match they're going to click
no and this is going to be a kind of
systematic process they're going to go
through one of these sub regions at a
time and ultimately make a final
decision now they're somewhat
constrained by the interface so they're
really supposed to be focusing on the
sub region or the the box that they're
in at that moment and you can see the
the border they're kind of helping them
now they're allowed to zoom in and they
can pan a little bit to kind of check
the edge to make sure that the target
area doesn't fall onto a into a crack so
to speak
but ultimately they're kind of
constrained to look into that one area
so back to the expert view theoretically
they are investigating this and on their
own pace and meanwhile crowd feedback is
starting to come in and these red boxes
are the no areas marked by the crowd and
the green areas are the yes maybe area
is marked by the crowd and the darker
the green the more agreement there was
from multiple workers indicating that
this is a more promising area so what we
can imagine is the expert would look at
this grid and if they trusted the crowd
they would ignore the red areas or spend
little time on those and they would
prioritize focusing on the green areas
so the expert is turning off this color
temporarily they can mark areas they've
already checked in black if they don't
find what they're looking for that keeps
them from accidentally searching the
same area twice it's usually easier to
investigate if you can turn those colors
off temporarily so that ability is there
and you have access to the variety of of
Google features so for example the two
and a half D mode might allow you to
make a comparison that's closer to the
ground photo so right around here I
think the expert is going to find
something that looks promising you can
see the blue border represents the the
cell that they're kind of in at that
moment so if they click exclude then
that one turns black or if they click
found it that's the area that will be
returned as the location that's been
found and sure enough this is a close
match and they found it little
anticlimactic but they found it hooray
okay so enveloping this system we had to
make a number of different choices and
we had to conduct some experiments to
really figure out which of these design
decisions led to the best results so
these two next experiments that I'll
talk about they're both kind of
connected to this question of the
diagram and it had a chicken and egg
problem here because first we were
wondering okay which would be better for
the crowd would it be the ground-level
photo or would it be the aerial diagram
but the other question we were wondering
was how much detail should be in that
diagram so there'd be a little bit of
detail or a lot of detail and we didn't
want to show we don't want to compare
the wrong level of detail against the
ground photo so we decided we would
first start by looking at the level of
detail in the diagram and once we found
the best level of detail then we would
compare that to the ground level photo
and see which works best so that leads
us into this next study we're trying to
figure out what's the best diagram that
we can provide to the crowd that will
allow them to perform this task as
effectively as possible and you can
imagine too much detail and they're
overwhelmed not enough detail and
everything looks like it and there's too
many false positives so instead of
reinventing the wheel we took some
inspiration from other kinds of people
who have attempted to abstract or sigh
lies Geographic data so we took a couple
of level of detail schemas from the 3d
graphics community and basically as you
go from low to high detail you start
adding more structural detail you start
adding vegetation etc so long story
short we ended up with these six levels
and they're cumulative so as you go from
top to bottom you start adding more and
more features and ultimately you end up
with the highest level detail so for our
experiment we wanted to compare these
three okay so on the one hand the lowest
level of detail just the bare minimum
Road boundaries on the other extreme
high level we're talking about trees
bushes that kind of stuff and then a
middle
and that's what we're going to be
experimenting with and exploring now
there's some questions here of course
what are the right images to even use to
draw these diagrams well we were lucky
to find a training set that one of our
experts used for doing geolocation
workshops so we figured okay if these
are considered good for training novices
to seem appropriate for our purposes to
the next question is how much work
should we give any individual worker and
you know from the the video that we're
asking workers to look at sixteen
different sub-regions per worker it
might seem like a lot for a crowd worker
why not just make it a micro task and
have one region at a time and we tried
that we found that we weren't getting
good performance
there wasn't enough context and very
often the sub-region would be too small
and they wouldn't get the full picture
some of it would be cut off and they
would mark that as a No and they would
come around to the other half later and
they would mark that as a no as well so
we for different amounts we tried grids
of twenty five and ultimately grids of
sixteen turned out to be the right
amount for Ultimo optimal performance
and finally how do you navigate these 16
should they just go randomly should they
go in a straight line
once again we can draw on some smart
people from other domains to help us
here so the search-and-rescue
communities think about this all the
time depends on kind of what you're
doing if you have a good idea of what
your where your starting point is you
might use the expanding square pattern
or using airplane you might use this
sector search but we're going to use the
creeping box because that's the that's
been found to be the best strategy when
you don't really have any idea within
the region where the locations likely to
be so these are the diagrams that we
ended up producing and you can see we
have low medium and high detail diagrams
for three locations Brasilia Los Angeles
Charlotte
these are you can see as we add in more
detail we start to getting vegetation
road markings things like that these are
going to be those three levels that
we're exploring so we conducted a
experiment on Mechanical Turk and we
have these three levels of detail we
have these three locations each worker
is getting this grade of 16 regions sub
regions one of them is correct 15 of
them are wrong and 60 workers are going
to be assigned to each combination of a
level of detail and a location we gave
them all ten minutes because we wanted
this to be a pretty quick process if
everyone takes 10 minutes then
theoretically we could have all the
results back in ten minutes as we can
parallel eyes and we paid them minimum
wage for our location based on the
amount of time that we saw most people
take and we measured two things the
quality of their results how accurate
they were basically and prioritization
how successfully would we be able to
recommend the most promising sub regions
to that expert and one final point to
make here is that this is a certain kind
of problem there's a lot of different
especially commercial satellite image
analysis sites where people are looking
for certain kinds of content or they're
marking damaged buildings or they're
looking for certain kinds of structures
this is a needle in haystack problem
which means that we are looking for only
one thing because it's a geolocation
there's only one location like it and
it's high importance if we miss it we're
in really big trouble so is anybody
found the one that's not a cue yet all
right
what well done that's the best I've seen
so far it is indeed over here we go tada
right
so that's what we're trying to do this
so the obstacle or facing area is a
cognitive bias from called the
prevalence effect which they surprise
says that if there's only one thing
people get tired after a while and they
stop looking for it and and so on and
this is really important for us to
overcome because this is fundamentally
what we're trying to do for geolocation
so we're going to look for two things to
try to get around this just to try to
measure this properly first we're gonna
look at the true positive rate which
means that if a sub-region was the
correct one how often did people say
that was a yes and then for the up
opposite false positives we're going to
say when this sub-region is a no and
it's when it's not the correct one how
often do people say that it was a yes
those are the two measures we're going
to look at finally when we were running
this study we first did some pilots and
we found that these individual workers
if we ask one person to look at each
sub-region we didn't get very good
results some people just weren't very
good at it they didn't try very hard
we're not sure but they didn't do so
well so we wanted to try different kinds
of aggregation have multiple workers do
the same task and aggregate or combine
their results in different ways we tried
a bunch of different things ultimately
what we found was a one yes rule for a
group of three workers yielded the best
results so for every region we're going
to have three different people look at
it and if any one of those people says
yes we're going to mark it as a
potential yes and when we tried to we
the the results weren't so good when we
tried different larger groups of workers
three five ten where results weren't so
good this turned out to be the best
balance of the two so that means that we
took these 60 workers that were in a
condition and we randomly formed groups
of three for our analysis so we end up
with twenty groups of three workers all
right so what do we find so first
looking at quality this is interesting
all of the workers regardless of the
level of detail did pretty good at
finding the
recked region so in the low and high
detail case about 92% of the time they
marked the correct region in the medium
detail case they founded 98% of the time
so there they're not missing it very
often what we didn't find is any
difference between the levels of detail
now sure in this particular experiment
medium did a little bit better but it
wasn't a statistically significant
difference of course finding the right
region is only important if they're
marking a lot of other regions as not
correct otherwise you could just mark
the whole thing so we have to look at
the false positive as well and here
we're seeing that regardless of which of
these three levels of detail we're
getting about half false positives so
that means that we're cutting down the
search space by about 50% and we're
still maintaining that correct region 92
to 98 percent of the time so looks
promising
once again we're not seeing a difference
in the level of detail although medium
seems to be doing a little bit better in
both of these in this particular case so
moving on to prioritization alright so
can these experts get suggested the more
promising locations better than chance
so when I say prioritization I'm talking
about of the group that we have marked
as a yes or a maybe how often do we do
more than one we twerker agree that that
location is is correct so we're using
that agreement to come up with a
prioritization scheme now because
there's only three levels of agreement
one worker two workers or three workers
we'd expect one third to be kind of our
chance and happily we see better results
than that anywhere oops anywhere from
about 70 to 85 percent we're getting
that better prioritization that means
we're correctly sending that expert to
the locations that are promising that
contain the correct sub region so what
we see here is regardless of
the level of detail we see the false
positives cut in half while maintaining
almost perfect true positives we did see
slightly better results for medium but
not significantly different for the
prioritization all of them were
significantly better than chance and the
low details seem to be a little bit
worse than the others so what we can
conclude I think here is that the
diagram does show promise remember none
of these people saw the ground-level
photo so the diagram shows promise
medium seems as good as anything maybe a
little bit better so we'll move it
forward with medium we have to pick one
of them so then our next question
becomes is this medium level diagram
actually going to be any better than
just showing someone the photo does this
abstraction actually improve accuracy or
improve efficiency and that's what this
next question is so we're going to
compare some crowd workers seeing the
ground level photo other ones seeing the
diagram and other ones get both and they
get to flip back and forth so maybe it's
maybe the shotgun approach is best we'll
give them both and they can choose when
they want to look at one of the other so
what we did was we took those diagrams
and here are the corresponding ground
level photos again this is from the
training data set and since we're
directly comparing diagrams to photos
this time we all we did some redaction
of the diagrams to show camera position
because these this content isn't visible
in the ground level photos it wouldn't
be a fair comparison so this is what
we're looking at now the study is pretty
much exactly the same setup except that
in this case the manipulation is diagram
photo or both instead of level of detail
and everything else is the same so we
can jump right into the results so look
into quality we find that using just the
diagram is significantly better for true
positives than just the ground level
photo so
if we provide someone with the
ground-level photo they're going to get
it the correct location 78% of the time
maybe not good enough if this is a
needle in the haystack problem and we
know that that crowd worker is going to
miss this one out of five times may not
want to use crowd workers if we're
giving them the ground-level photo but
if we're giving them the diagram and we
get this 98% true positives now we're
talking
now this is a situation where the
diagram is clearly better and it's good
enough that we might actually want to
use it the both turned out to be almost
as good as as the diagram but not quite
as good so surprisingly perhaps it's
better not to show the photo than to
show just the diagram for false
positives very similar across no
significant differences once again we're
getting that 50% error rate
so we can say a couple things about this
we can say all right regardless of which
reference material we're going to get
about fifty percent return rate which is
pretty good and more than that the
increase in true positives that we get
with the diagram doesn't result in
increase in false positives so there's
no cost to using the diagram so last
thing is let's look at that
prioritization again prioritization
again telling us if we're pointing that
expert to the right locations using
agreement no significant difference
these are all basically similar the
ground level did a little bit better in
our experiments but it's not a
significant difference and once again
these prioritization levels are pretty
good about double what we would get from
chance so a couple of conclusions we can
draw from study number three
as I suggested a minute ago we're
getting much better true positives with
the diagram and a realistic level of
quality that we could actually imagine
crowdsourcing is
regardless of which technique we're
getting about forty to sixty percent
false positive so we're cutting on that
search space by about half and again
that prioritization holds up we're
getting about double the prioritizations
that we would get from chance so we're
really focusing that expert on the most
important areas so finally and again
this is just a little bit of a teaser
this isn't a full study yet we want to
actually bring experts into the loop
here and conveniently we have some
experts from our interview study they
told us all the things that were hard
about this and all the things they would
like to see and so we went back to them
we said hey we listened to you and we
built this a piece of software would you
actually like to try it out on some
tasks and we're kind of in the middle of
doing that right now we've had a handful
of people try it already I'll give you a
couple of their high level comments so
far but really we want to see how this
helps them and our idea right now is
we're going to give them three tasks and
thirty minutes to do them to kind of
simulate that hectic real-world
environment where they have a lot of
work to do at the same time and the
parallelization of the crowd could be a
real advantage here so some examples of
what the crowd and expert produced so
here's the test image we provided here's
an expert diagram and here's some crowd
results again we're seeing that 50
percent area again here's another one
these diagrams are pretty interesting at
least to me and then finally one more
example of the Los Angeles location and
the crowd results we did some interviews
after these tasks we asked people to
talk about they would really use this or
what their reactions were this
particular participant one of the
journalists really emphasized the
multitasking advantages of this so he
says I'm going through this video and
I'm doing all these different things
blah blah blah if I was doing that and I
could say these are the coordinates for
the town and use the search radius and
these are the things I'm looking for I
could probably do it in 60 percent of
the time that would normally take well
that's an empirical question we'll find
out but I hope he's right and I think
you might be
some other comments people talking about
what it would like to get that crowd
feedback and how they integrate it into
their work practice experts were saying
oh so yeah I'm taking advantage of that
feedback I'm looking where the darkest
greens are and I'm zooming in there I
paid more attention to those and less
attention to the red and this particular
expert who performed the best and got
all three locations actually completely
ignored the red locations said forget it
I'm just going to go with it with the
crowds word on this one and focus on the
greens so for next steps we're excited
to complete that study get more experts
running through using the system and
understand how it affects them their
performance their attitudes how it
changes our work practice we also want
to do longitudinal study where they're
using real images of performing real
geolocation tasks on images that they
need to identify for their for their
jobs we're also interested kind of
beyond this whole satellite image ground
truth problem what other elements of the
geolocation process might crowds be able
to help with we're mostly focusing here
on this process of mapping and
ground-level photo onto satellite
imagery but that process was quite long
and as you saw there a number of
different steps like gathering context
or looking for clues and the image
content where we can imagine
crowdsourcing with its variety and its
parallelization could be an advantage as
well so for some final thoughts just
kind of wrapping this up as I said at
the beginning I think that experts in
crowds have some complementary strengths
and that empirical studies like the one
that we performed can help us show us
what the experts need and where the
crowd might be able to help in this case
we're looking at geolocation and we saw
that with this ground truth system
crowds that use the diagrams can narrow
down that search space by about half
while maintaining the correct location
and and prioritization prioritizing it
about half as well as chance
and then finally geolocation
is kind of one domain for one example of
where expert-led crowdsourcing might be
valuable but I think there
likely be many others and so I encourage
all of you to consider or contribute to
thinking about what those possibilities
might be how could we get these
complementary strengths working together
I think there's a lot of potential there
so that I will say thank you first of
all to my wonderful students that worked
on this project a combination of
computer science and national security
students we also had a number of
participants from Mechanical Turk as
well as our experts and many others and
of course my funding and I want to thank
all of you for listening and being a
great attentive audience so thank you
[Applause]
machine vision at all like um like and I
know there are certain contexts in which
it seemed like like like machinery some
techniques could be helpful for example
that one where you had like the rooftops
teachers and like findell Eastern and
then stuff like have you considered like
hybrid approaches or like they just not
all or great question yeah I'm really
excited about the potential Firebird
approaches and there's actually been
some some pretty nice work in the
computer vision community on geolocation
different approach is seen
classification for some neural nets
stuff more recently I think there's a
mixed initiative system that has a
little bit of computer vision a little
bit of crowdsourcing might be the best
of both worlds we haven't really
explored that too much yet what we saw
is some of the main limitations of the
the computer vision approach is they
often require either a really big
database or a really specific idea of
what you're looking for ahead of time
and in this case we didn't really have
either of those things
so the crowdsourcing approach maybe a
little bit more general-purpose but I'm
excited to talk to other experts in
computer vision and see if there's an
opportunity there yeah yeah
can share an encounter or my collection
okay uh it actually it seems like
recognizing contour is a bit you boiled
it down or the experts have boiled it
down to a really shallow considered as a
problem and it and you know you have
these people in Virginia basically doing
pattern recognition on us frees you from
la they're doing what they're people
aren't really good at which like you
said you know looking for a barrel in
the power tools and without any
comparison at all to it to even a week
computer vision attentive installation
it's it's hard to take it seriously
well that's a fair that's a fair comment
I think one thing to keep in mind is
that this practice is pretty much a
manual process right now what we know
from our expert interviews is that the
experts are doing a lot of this work on
their own
so they're using open source tools they
might be doing some collaboration with
that with fellow experts but most of
this is just them sitting at a computer
processing this information so it seems
like there's a fruitful area of work for
considering ways to help these experts
our approach is to take some take
crowdsourcing and bring it into this
equation but I can imagine
computer vision approach is working well
also another important thing to keep in
mind is these reference images that are
being used the satellite images are come
from a variety of sources some of them
are from Googlers some of them are from
very recent images from Tara server
stuff that was produced maybe in the
last day or two so if we have automated
techniques they need to have access to
all those data sources we need to make
sure that all the latest satellite tiles
from the last day can be fed into our
reference database we need to make sure
that images from being and other
services can be used so if we don't have
that infrastructure
it may be more difficult to easily move
between those sources what's nice about
the crowdsourcing approach is it's a
little more generic we can point a crowd
or human to any of these sources with
very little overhead and say here's an
image source go for it
so there's there's kind of a set-up cost
there that's gets reduced yeah the
magical step for me is when you use an
expert to take the mic front on a vision
of the building and have the expert
think about what it would look like from
the top down and have a nice simple
representation of that that then was
interpretable to me if I sum the streets
were more interpreting than the first
one but had like bosses in line that
seems like an extraordinarily hard
machine vision algorithm to know how to
map that like because those things
aren't accurate they're very much
identified in a way that humans really
know how to do that well those
abstractions seem to be the key thing
that the experts could add to the system
to help guide user knowledge users yeah
that that diagram exactly there any
other representations of experts have
that you thought could also use this
sort of approach that like representing
it right way then let people make it a
matching problem yeah that's good that's
a great point I'm just kind of
reiterating what you said but it's it's
an abstraction but it's not a it's not a
perfect replica it's not a perfect
abstraction right and luckily this kind
of diagram is interprete Balai human and
so they're able to say well even though
the proportions aren't quite right the
gist of it here seems to be well within
the range that we're looking for maybe
to some extent some of those same like
fuzzy matches could be accomplished with
computer vision ultimately though we
still have that expert at the end of the
day that's able to say well this was
flagged as a potential match but I have
the ability to make that final call yeah
it's good thing about what other
possibilities might be recognizable by a
human that's a little more abstract a
little more stylized
[Applause]
you